you know some of you may remember that
one of my all-time favorite stories is
hanging out with Brad Pitt in New
Orleans as he helped to rebuild the
Ninth Ward after it was decimated by
Hurricane Katrina
well Brad's at it again and he's doing
it with some very famous friends
Michelle Turner joins us now she has the
story
hey Michelle Oh mr. Frazier watching
Brad with the property brothers was
everything I needed but there's so much
you don't know about that
and how Brad is spending his time in
quarantine
Brad's quarantine includes staying
hashtag safe at home
there have been no public sightings in
six weeks yes Brad has seen the kids and
as for this tabloid headline that says
he's been spending the past 22 days
locked away with Jennifer Aniston we're
not buying it instead Brad's focusing on
another woman in his life she's a dear
old friend but there's people in your
life that fate brings together and I'm
forever grateful I love her with all my
heart that would be his makeup artist
Jean she's been with the oscar-winner
since his days in Fight Club mr. and
mrs. Smith and once upon a time in
Hollywood and she has seen it all there
was a time on legend to fall she had to
make up my butt because of bad tan lines
and it's something when it comes up we
can't really look each other in the eye
all we had is ten grads episode of the
property brothers newest show celebrity
IOU premiered last night no script just
a raw look at mr. pip what we learn
jeans bungalow home in Santa Monica is
one of the places he likes to hide out
if I'm over here on the west side I'll
often pissed up here get a nap on the
couch now thanks to Drew and Jonathan's
three-week renovation on jeans garage
when Brad makes his pit stop this is his
new Murphy bed I'll take me probably a
day or two to remember how to get the
bed at help it's one answer Oh should we
practice that's condescending
it was HR Brad's go-to stance is this
cool i'ma just lean against the wall
smile and look handsome moon plus he
loves getting his hands dirty if I'm not
building I'm dying need any more reason
to love him the 56 year old also has a
giant heart he knew this very special
detail would mean the world to Jeanne
her father passed when she was very
young and then her mother when she was
young lady and they were very very very
tog that's gonna get her so I'm the guys
gonna if he's gonna cry on television
this I I can't even tell you I don't
even know yet I can't take it all in
just hear what it will mean to her we
really sweet seeing him try to fight
through those emotions of oh boy I
didn't know I was gonna get this
emotional about this process when he saw
her tear up he couldn't hold it back and
all I thought about my mind was I made
my dick dry for you to just think about
it's really well my main goal was just
to get you on television we do practice
lines don't look what you made me do
look what you made me do
that's the one
[Music]